tambóv in southern Russia and a monument
to the fallen of the Second World War
was known here as the Great Patriotic
War
but Vladimir Putin denies there are any
Russian soldiers in Ukraine that his
military is involved in that conflict at
all the deaths of three young servicemen
tell a different story
Anton savelii of was from Tambov whom of
the elite 16th brigade spans Nats he
died on the 5th of May he was about to
turn 21 Russian bloggers connected Anton
to two other soldiers who died on the
same day they appeared to be from the
same unit their friend said they died
performing their military duty but there
are no public reports about their deaths
at Anton's grave we found reads from
comrades and the command of the unit on
the trickler of the Russian flag the
writing on the wreaths reads to the
defender of the fatherland from the
Ministry of Defence of the Russian
Federation so if we go through the
potentially plausible innocent
explanations the first is that this man
died doing his legitimate duty somewhere
that was not Ukraine in which case why
was the no reporting of it in the
Russian media the second is that he was
no longer a serving soldier at the time
of his death but in which case why is
the Russian Ministry of Defence sending
flowers to his funeral
the preferred boobarella this lady knows
the family she asked us not to show her
face she said it's meant to be a secret
but everyone knows he died in Ukraine
they were sent to Rostov and in Ukraine
in Ukraine everything is done quietly we
don't know where exactly but somewhere
there
it's Ukraine's fault that he died of
course it's a shame that we died for not
her mother
Anton had posted this photo of himself
at the 16th brigade memorial
but when we asked at the base they
denied they'd heard of him or any of the
three we flew to oofah in central Russia
and then by rude to the Republic of
Tatarstan the home of Timur Amamiya soup
of social media post showed Timur on the
right with the Spetsnaz flag his service
medal from Crimea last year but also
with the flag of the separatist Lugansk
People's Republic and in front of a
distinctive APC the same vehicle seen
here and known to be used by the rebels
in East Ukraine in teamers village we
found everyone knew him they said he was
a Russian soldier who died as a hero his
grave is strikingly similar to Anton's
the same date of death the same wreath
from the Minister of Defense and the
unit command we traveled with Ruslan
Leviev he's coordinating social media
research into these graves despite
receiving death threats himself longer
this war goes on then what people died
that's why we're doing our best to stop
this war and show people there are no
fascism in Ukraine that those in power
are lying even to their soldiers they
abandoned them those who were captured
and died Tamera's mother told us she got
a notice from the military that he died
in the North Caucasus event
there are no reports of Russian military
casualties around this date she's
certain he was still a serving soldier I
told him that if you get sent to Ukraine
let me know he said mum if they send me
to Ukraine I will go I won't refuse but
I will warn you about it
we drove east into the Ural Mountains
and towards the border with Kazakhstan
by the side of the road we met up with a
man who'd rant Ruslan's original blog
and decided to investigate the death of
the man from his region even card Apollo
he asked us to conceal his identity a
van was pictured with Timur close to the
Ukrainian border and with the same white
markings the rebels are using to
identify themselves we framed the same
date May the 5th and the same wreaths on
his grave federal security officers were
reportedly at the funeral when the body
came to the funeral there was a lot of
his be officer the comrades of Iran they
came with the with the Parata uniform to
pay the last respect to day one and the
KGB officers asked them to take this
uniform away and the comrades told that
they will not do it and they pay the
last respect to even with the fulbright
with the pirate uniform the three men
each came from poor rural villages far
from the centre of power from families
without the resources to challenge the
authorities we kick up a fuss the family
doesn't want to speak about it on camera
but they've told us they got a notice
from the military that he died in the
North Caucasus but other people in the
village are telling us they've heard he
died in East Ukraine
whispering court official on the Burmese
social contract upon a time Bolivian
will not only keep in close the
dimension is the Santa
a number of people told us these men
died heroically but if they did serving
their country and not in Ukraine why is
their government silent about their
deaths we put these questions to
Russia's Ministry of Defense but have
yet to receive a response President
Putin has since declared the deaths of
Russian soldiers during so-called
special operations a state secret though
no such operations have yet been
announced KT stalard Sky News central
Russia